what took place tonight against your
rival on this stage i don't know i
haven't had a chance to think about it
all i know is that this has been a group
of perseverance and toughness and
resiliency i've said that i said over
the last two two and a half months this
group is so together the health of this
team in this program is at its finest
and i'm just so proud of them seeing
them continue to have experiences and
testimonies and stories out there i'm
just telling you as a coach it brings so
much joy to me to see these guys have a
smile on their face and come up big this
is a beautiful moment how about for you
for this program to bring it back to
where you said you wanted it to be i see
the tears where do those come from well
it is i talked to you about it the other
day that i wanted
you know i felt like over the last two
or three years north carolina wasn't
relevant north carolina should never be
irrelevant it should be front and center
with the spotlight on them on players
like caleb and rj and i just um i'm so
happy for him i'm so happy for our
program our university it's a beautiful
day for carolina basketball thanks a lot
and i'll bring in caleb caleb just six
points in that first half 21 in the
second what got into you here how bad
did you want this one i wanted it bad
you know
playing duke
to the chance to get to the national
championship you know
it's crazy that i'm here right now i'm
just blessed and i'm glad to do with my
teammates
now you're on to win a national
championship that is your goal on monday
night again against kansas what will it
take for this team to carry this into
monday night just our togetherness and
our toughness you know kansas is a great
team they like to uh their pace is one
of the
top one in the nation and so we got to
stop them in transition and then we just
got to play our game
go enjoy this one thank you
our visit the other night with hubert
he talked about how important it is to
honor coach smith coach guthridge
coach williams
he had tears in his eyes as he talked
about it
it is an amazing
achievement
genuine joy there huh
[Applause]